hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where today we are talking
about the xbox series x and xbox series
x
finally getting a release date and a
price i believe this was all
leaked by brad sams
um but this is on windows central that i
am sourcing here pretty good sources
so literally as i was uploading this
video i fully edited uh xbox tweeted
this saying
let's make it official xbox series x
next-gen performance in the smallest box
ever 299 confirmed and then they say
looking forward to sharing more soon
promise means we're probably gonna get
another press conference pretty soon
um but interesting note that i didn't
get to cover in the rest of this video
because we didn't know
the smallest xbox ever so that's pretty
cool um back to the original video
this happened while i was streaming um
and initially i wasn't even gonna make a
video about it because
i'm always of the mindset that i don't
find the prices and release dates
particularly interesting like that's not
the conversation about next-gen that i
find interesting at all
and i feel like it comes up so so so
frequently that i'm just kind of
bored of it what i care about is video
games
and how the pieces of hardware um are
furthering the medium and what cool
innovations we will get with the
development of new hardware
so that's what i'm always on the lookout
for and the conversations that i always
want to have this stuff
less interesting but i am always
interested from a business perspective
and there is something in here that i
think confirms a theory that i had
uh that made me want to make the video
ultimately to get to the news for anyone
who missed it i'm just kind of assuming
everyone's already seen it because at
this point it's hours old which
on the internet means years really but
basically
the xbox series s console design finally
leaked it is this one right here i think
it looks weird as hell
i guess i always think that new consoles
look weird as hell until i kind of get
used to them but
i should that what what is this
ultimately not
that different to the one x without the
disk drive but
you this big boy on the top uh the xbox
series s
is 2.99 the series x is 4.99 and they
will both launch on november 10th
2020. 4.99 is basically exactly what i
expected i think i'm not surprised by
that price
in either direction but it's also for
the people who care about console wars
which again not a thing i care about no
matter what i'm gonna get both
it doesn't matter to me um this price
ultimately means nothing unless you have
the playstation 5 price
to compare it to and one thing that's so
weird about this whole thing is like why
didn't microsoft
like the xbox series s everyone knew it
existed everyone had already been
talking about it
i just don't know why they didn't
announce it themselves like the last
console generation
we at this time of year we already knew
how much they were and when they were
coming out i just don't know
what this weird like trying to keep
things secret strategy is when
just everything's leaking just just tell
i just don't know why they just haven't
just told us like it's
it's so strange to watch for anyone who
hasn't heard the xbox series s
um yeah has been rumored for a long time
we don't know very much about it but it
seems like it's basically just
a less powerful version of the xbox
series x
as it says here it is roughly around as
powerful as the xbox one x
uh perhaps geared towards 1080p monitors
with better frame rates
but that is all we really know
um windows central here says we expect
nvme drives and many of the new and
next-gen features like fast resuming
multiple games and retracing i love free
tracing trace
those rays bro we obviously know more
about the series x
12 teraflops 4k resolution
60 frames a second uh halo infinite will
be up to 120 frames a second in
multiplayer
however the thing that i did want to
mention here is is what i think is the
most interesting part of this and what i
think will change
basically home consoles going forward or
at least that microsoft is trying to
push for that change and we'll see if it
works
is xbox all access um i don't have a
terrible amount to say about
either of these consoles or the prices
or any of that stuff again i really just
care about video games
xbox all access is interesting
uh if you haven't heard of it let's just
see what windows central or how they
describe it neatly
it is a subscription service dubbed xbox
all access granting users the
opportunity to split the cost of an xbox
console and associated subscriptions
over two years
this specifically lists here the xbox
series x will cost
2.99 at retail with a 25 per month xbox
all access financing option
and the xbox series x will cost 4.99
with a 35
per month xbox all access financing
option to give some background before i
get to like my point about what i think
this means
and i think i don't like it
um but i'm unsure right now i'd have to
think about it a bit longer
when they first came out with the xbox
one x uh especially the xbox one
i guess and then the xbox series s was
rumored and then the xbox series
x so he's like oh my god microsoft what
are you doing with these
names it's it's so all over the place
can we just get a number or just
something more simple
now with this all-access financing
option
all of this makes a bit more sense to me
i previously had this attitude of like
if
your parent is going to buy their kid an
xbox series x or an xbox series x
at retail for christmas or for
thanksgiving or whatever
they're gonna get so confused seeing all
these things listed uh they're gonna get
so confused with these different names
it just is so weird in terms of
marketing
um but i think that the case
now is that that is almost intentional
so a
basically they're going the mobile phone
route what they are trying to do
is get a recurring um subscription
service that would obviously tie into
game pass and i very much think
that with all of this uh context the
xbox series s
is a game pass box that is going to be
bundled with game pass
probably push xcloud it is very much
going
to be a here's this cheap thing where
you get game pass you subscribe we get
this and then we upgrade you
the minute that your subscription is
done the exact same way that phones work
so the titles now make sense to me
because you know
your parents understand an iphone x and
an iphone s and an s plus they
boomers get that [ __ ] you know if they
are capable of understanding iphone and
android phone upgrades
um even though those names can sometimes
be kind of ridiculous
then an xbox series x and an xbox series
s
are not that complicated to understand
especially if you go to a retailer and
you say which of these two do i get and
you are sold from the jump which i think
is what will probably happen
this subscription service with this one
this subscription service with this one
here's the price difference here's the
hardware difference they all have the
same games
you will get subscription boxes long
term that you will upgrade over time
which is the most telling part of what i
think all of this means
is that we are going to get consoles a
lot more frequently than we're getting
them right now
at least from microsoft it doesn't mean
that sony's doing this uh nintendo has
been doing this for
ages the ds ds lite the dsi and
3ds and the 2ds and the 3ds xl and the
new 3ds xl oh
nintendo have been doing this [ __ ] for a
while obviously it works fantastically
in the mobile phone world um and
i don't really know how i feel about
what it means for the industry more
broadly if we are getting
way more hardware also from microsoft on
one hand it could mean that if hardware
is constantly iterating and the minute
that your subscription expires they send
you a notice for the new
xbox series s and you just upgrade to
that then
video games software will not be as
held back by old hardware as it has been
previously
but same token with xbox's focus on
backwards compatibility and everything
being available and everything
i don't know if that works the same way
either but certainly i think this is
what they're trying to do is sell you
the xbox series x as your way to get all
of the apps that are available
on the app store which is really just
game pass and to keep you paying money
for a thing
regardless of how much you do or don't
use it obviously it's a lot cheaper than
a phone subscription you're probably not
gonna use your xbox as much as you use
your phone
but that's my point there the xbox
series x is
probably essentially the same thing um
and an interesting one that i'm sure
i've mentioned this in in videos before
but i kind of just wanted to touch on
again
people keep saying what's the point in
buying an xbox series x if i have a pc
the answer is there isn't one uh i have
a pc i don't need an xbox series x there
there is no point it is ultimately
just a more powerful box for people who
still want a home console game pass is
the thing that they're trying to sell
you across the board
subscriptions are the thing that they're
trying to sell you across the board uh
hardware manufacturers don't make that
much money off of the consoles
themselves it is very much
about getting you into those
subscription services right now so where
the xbox series x is concerned my answer
is still
i don't think if you have a pcdo happy
with
that you need to buy an xbox series
exital don't you could just get game
pause from pc and have a very similar
experience on your more customizable
hardware
they're still selling that one with that
35 per month xbox all access financing
option which i look forward to hearing
more about i really am unsure how i feel
about this could be bad
could be good i don't know how i feel
yet and i just want to reiterate
something that i've said before that i
think i've said like
for a long time ultimately i really
don't think the console was exist
anymore and i feel like this furthers
that
uh it is very much microsoft focusing
on subscriptions and services and making
their money that way and also streaming
i know if phil spencer has said that he
considers their competitors to be people
like apple and amazon where it seems
like playstation is staying traditional
uh and continuing to i imagine work on
huge blockbuster exclusives uh really
solid
single player titles of course they also
want you to be part of their
subscription services because that's how
they make a lot of money
but i don't know that they will go the
mobile phone route maybe that will
happen depending on how successful it is
for microsoft i'm not sure
but there is no console at war anymore
of this thing sold this much and this
thing sold this much
um because that's not the game
that these companies are playing
microsoft is not trying to sell
a significant amount of xboxes i do
think
it is basically guaranteed that ps5 will
sell better than either of these xboxes
in my opinion
but microsoft will be measuring success
in terms of subscriptions
subscribers which of their financing
options they are subscribed to and
how much revenue they make from those
things playstation will probably
still be measuring success in terms of
actual units sold so
it's just a very different landscape
things are changing and it feels like
they're changing
very quickly i don't know if it's always
felt this way but this one
just like the jump from the ps2 to ps3
era
to ps4 to ps5 era like it just feels
huge
and i really don't know how i feel about
it
i'm conflicted because i love just
single player games that i can just play
by myself
and zone out on which obviously
playstation are still making a lot of
and i fully appreciate them for that
but if microsoft makes a ton of money
doing this then that could all shift in
this favor i really don't know what's
gonna happen it's uh
it's an interesting one and yeah the
again the price the release date
ultimately meant nothing to me the xbox
all access financing option
is what i think the big news is here but
yes
um that's a rant from me wow nice work
green screen
really doing a great job here today
wonderful
all right i'll see you guys next time
bye